good hi welcome
are you alive
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hi welcome
[Music]
okay let's try this
how many of you are building
browser-based uis
okay how many of you are using regular
javascript for that
i don't believe you
and how many of you are using binary
javascript it's called webassembly
a couple of you as well okay
so to be you know full disclosure
i don't care about uis at all
i
never had the urge to write a user
interface i was always a server guy
where the world is so much you know
easier and peaceful than in the browser
but we have customers of course which
are doing these types of applications
and for the last you know 10 years
uh you know like we helped them building
these types of applications and uh
you know it
i really felt bad for them because so
many times the other that the guidance
has changed from do this and do not do
this and then it was the opposite around
like you you have to do this but don't
do this anymore right um
so you know
as i said many times the things have
changed and um
i hope i really hope we are now at a
point where kind of like we we find a
good middle ground of how to build these
applications both
from a ux point of view and from a
security point of view and of course i
only care about the security part um but
but still you know like we need to
satisfy um
both yeah
so
um
my name is dominic i do security for a
living
and
if you want to contact me here on my
contact details and there's also the
slides the slides of today's talk are
also on um uploaded to speaker deck so
if you want to have them
just
just grab them from there
good so what's our agenda um
i basically want to go back in time a
little bit and look at some history how
we build browser-based applications
um
you know and depending you know and that
might you know have having a look how
things have changed over time and you
might be even you know like in one era
or the other or might be stuck even and
can't upgrade or maybe you haven't
started yet and and and can then realize
okay that's not how we do it anymore
right so that's kind of the idea of the
first part of the talk
to look a little bit back in time how
things have been done and what are the
issues with these approaches yeah
and then once we have that we're going
to look at basically the current best
practice right which is the this thing
called back-end for front-end pattern
and there are a couple of variations of
that even um already
um and
we're gonna look at these two and then
at the end i'm gonna show you how you
could build your own yeah because
actually all the building blocks are
there you just need to put them together
in the right
order
before we start i want to set the scene
yeah um a couple of a couple of months
ago
a blog post i've written in 2019
made it oh 2020 made it to hacker news
okay and i got like basically shredded
to pieces uh on on hacker news uh
because apparently people only read the
headline and not the second line but he
said i get it was kind of a joke yeah
but
but uh yeah they said like oh this guy
says spas are dead he's so wrong yeah um
but what i was alluding to in this blog
post is that there are up that there are
browser changes already present and
coming up that make it harder and harder
to write a traditional spa yeah and what
this really was was a continuation of an
older blog post i wrote in 2019 where i
was researching an alternative way to
secure spas and by the way um whenever i
say spa that also includes blazer yeah
if you're here for the blazer part
the rules are exactly the same it's code
running in your browser just you know
it looks a little bit different
so
um
but the one good piece of feedback i got
was that yeah i mean there are so many
different types of reasons why you want
to write a browser-based application and
all i was talking about was how they are
becoming less and less useful for the
types of customers i have and the types
of applications they are writing yeah
and that is you know
boring
business applications i guess yeah
business applications where the front
end runs in the browser you are having
an authentication system you want to
connect to for you know single sign-on
federation all of these things and you
want to call apis from within that
front-end typically using oauth right so
that's the
the that's where i live basically and
that's what i meant with spas are dead
when it comes to this type
of architecture yeah i totally agree
that there are other types of spas out
there which don't have these things and
they might not be affected by what i'm
saying uh now
or maybe they are
good so let's start with um
way back in time right um you basically
let's say you had an asp.net webforms
application or something like this right
and at some point
the industry trend was this new thing
called ajax style right
i can literally remember
microsoft demos on stage with the ajax
control toolkit right they press the
button said look no flickering
isn't that great yeah um you know
it was great um
they started shipping jquery with the
product right so that people can do
their own no flickering web applications
yeah um and the nice part was it just
worked right you just wrote a little bit
of javascript you called an api and by
the way browsers work by the time you
know basically you use cookie-based
authentication the cookies were just
flowing back to your back-end there was
no extra code to write for the security
it just worked
until cross-site request for tree was
discovered
yeah and cross-site request forgery
is um basically um
a nice hack right so the idea is
basically you have your browser right
and think of the browser as an operating
system running multiple applications uh
some of them are trusted some of them
are not trusted right and you go to your
trusted application you know app.com
whatever you login
the browser sends you an authentication
cookie and from that point on when your
application makes ajax calls or
postbacks
the cookie just flows back to the server
and all is good yeah but now let's say
you're opening another tab in the
browser and you go to evil.com right and
evil.com starts now making http calls to
your real application right and the way
that browsers work is they say like oh
go i got a cookie from app.com and this
application is making a call to app.com
let's just send that cookie along
right and what that
essentially means is that the evil
application can now make network calls
to the other application impersonating
the currently locked on user in the
other tab that's cross-site request
forgery yeah amazon was funnily enough
one of the first companies got hit by
that you remember the one click buy
button where you basically had a link
you clicked the link you bought a book
right that used the fact that there was
an existing cookie session going on in
the browser so if i would now bring up
some website have an image tag on the
website set the source to the one click
buy button link you come to the website
you are logged onto amazon you buy my
book right fun
um
so
i always have people in the room saying
like this can't be true
if that would be true the whole web
would be broken and yeah you're probably
not wrong
um so what i have here is it's a simple
app right um i'm logging into this app
nothing special right i'm logged in i'm
you know just set the cookie and then
i'm doing work as alice yeah and now i
have another app here which is called
the evil app yeah
and let's bring this up and see what it
does
i mean who could resist right
um let's have a look what evil app is
actually doing
you see here here's my click here and
what it does is it basically does a
cross site post to another application
which is my app running in the other tab
of the browser and you know there's not
even javascript necessary for that i'm
just making the user click a button i'm
contacting an endpoint on the other
application and of course when i'm doing
that
i'm doing work as alice just evil work
now and you can imagine this this post
back could be automated with javascript
could be even in a hidden iframe right
there all kinds of things you could do
here
that's cross-site request forgery
so how can we protect against this
this mitigation technique is pretty much
known to everyone and that the reason
for that is because microsoft put it
pretty much into every template since
they released nbc it's called
anti-forgery protection right and the
idea is basically when you are rendering
down your form you are setting a special
cookie called the anti-forgery cookie
and you're setting a hidden input field
on the form
and the values of the two are the same
okay and when
the page posts back to the server
there's a filter running the validate
anti-forgery token filter who then looks
at the cookie looks at the hidden field
and if they match all is good right
that was pretty much automatic yeah
for api calls this wasn't automatic
because you're not doing postbacks right
and i i've done lots and lots of code
reviews in my life where uh all you know
like they had the anti-forgery
protection for the forms but they didn't
have it for the hx calls because it
meant things doing like getting their
verification token from from the form
setting it on a header manually posting
it to the server writing some custom
code in the server
and so on yeah so that's that's the cesa
of problem yeah and
when we go to our
uh controller here right our home
controller
um and i would put in the
validate and defautory
um
attribute here
and would run this again
and would go to uh
evil app i guess
it wouldn't work anymore right so that
was an easy fix um but as i said only
only it was only either this because it
was built into asp.net the
ajax call protection was never built
into asp.net and actually most people
many people i i spoke to didn't even
know about this problem
so
that is real
okay
so that's the cookie era yeah
um
with all of these problems with these
sea surf attacks and so on and other
ways how to exploit cookies um the ietf
picked up the problem back in 2008
9 something like this
and um
and said like okay how how about we get
rid of cookies and we are um exchanging
with with tokens with oauth tokens right
so instead of sending the cookie to the
api endpoint we are sending the token to
the api endpoint and the big difference
is that the token does not get sent
automatically you have to do extra work
for that and the browser is not involved
with this so the c-serve problem goes um
away right
so funny side story if you go back to
history in the ietf you can read all of
the communication and when somebody in
2008 or so said like maybe we should in
introduce an overflow for javascript
applications the first answer was why
would you ever write an application with
javascript right
so times have changed um
so
they said okay let's do this
but again going back 10 years in time
they had to find a way to get a token
from a server that purely and only uh
involved browser redirects because there
was no cross-origin hx calls by the time
that they didn't work right so they made
a lot of security compromises and came
up with this thing called
the implicit flow okay
that one is deprecated by now for good
um but the way the implicit flow worked
is the browser makes a redirect to the
token server requests the token the
token server sends the token back on the
url right then the javascript has to
store the token in the browser and then
it can start calling apis
now
the issue with this approach was
um
well store you know transmitting secrets
over a url was never a good idea
yeah there are so many ways how you can
leak that data right log files proxies
browser history right
or just plain implementation errors and
that's why this this flow by now is
heavily discouraged and soon will be
removed from the oauths back all to x
all together with the new revision with
oauth 2.1 now
so
now fast forwarding to 2020 whatever
they said like okay uh we have solved
the cross origin ajax problem we can now
make ajax calls to get the token and we
don't have to have to store it on the
url right so they
then the intermediary guidance was don't
use implicit flow anymore don't use
cookies anymore use the authorization
code flowing over yeah and the way the
authorization code flowing over works is
that the browser makes the redirect to
the offer to the authorization server
and then collects the so-called
authorization code which is just an
artifact that is on its own not
sensitive and then the javascript makes
an ajax call to the token endpoint and
retrieves the data so to speak on the
back channel right problem solved right
the url is clean now all good
um
[Music]
let me show you
an example that is using this style of
code
um it's the spar
right so basically what you did is you
got a javascript library which which
does all of the coordination going back
and forth right and that's exactly what
i'm doing here i'm i'm pulling in
an open connect client javascript
library i'm configuring all my stuff my
authority client id the authorization
code response type
and so on right
[Music]
and then
if i run this
i can now
control everything from javascript
there are no more cookies no more urls
are being harmed here so i can press
login
log into the server
and here i am i have my identity i have
my identity token of my access token and
now i can start calling apis yeah like
when if i would press this button here
i i would now be able to call an api
directly from javascript with the access
token great
um
[Music]
or maybe not
[Laughter]
so the next challenge we have is
by virtue of that everything is now
driven by javascript we have to store
these access tokens somewhere right and
they are they are sensitive data you
don't want to lose them you don't want
to leak them you don't want that
somebody exfiltrates these tokens and of
course because everything is running in
javascript you have to store the tokens
in the browser right in memory local
storage
session storage whatever right somewhere
but all of these storage mechanisms are
by definition accessible by javascript
right and guess what there's a new
attack well it wasn't really new but
um now had a new
importance which is called cross-site
scripting or if you want to
have a general term code injection
attacks right so if your application has
a cross-site scripting vulnerability an
attacker could inject javascript code in
your application which would read the
token from wherever you store it and
send it along to a different application
right the attackers application
and this
threat and vulnerabilities are far away
from being solved in javascript right i
mean we are making progress with all
kinds of complicated stuff we had on top
like uh
content security policies or uh is it
called trusted types now in react and
and so on and so forth but still if you
look at the os top 10 since ever
code injection is in the top three it's
just going up and down between one and
three uh wherever you know but it's
there right and if you look at new
research you you remember that there
were these specter attacks where you can
basically read send weird packages to a
server and then read arbitrary memory
from the server guess what they also
apply to browsers yeah so google has
found out that there are even in chrome
spectre attacks where an attacker
potentially you know can read ram
and if that ram is your access token
right so long story short
i don't want to store my tokens in the
browser it's way too dangerous
okay
um so you know go back to our uh app
here here's my token right and if i look
at
session storage in this case
here are the tokens right and if i am i
am now a clever attacker i can write
some javascript code read them from
session storage and send them anywhere i
want no
um
and then all of the other things yeah
that all of the little browser
differences like maybe so for example in
safari in incognito mode there is no
session storage so you can't use that
for example yeah and you have to come up
with other ways of doing these things
yeah
um so that's challenge number one
challenge number two is now once you
have that token and let's just ignore
for a second that the token is not
really secure because it's in the
browser how do you manage the token
right tokens have a lifetime when the
lifetime is over you want to get a new
token how do you in the in your spa
front end uh notice that the user has
locked out and you want to you know like
clean your data delete the tokens you
know session management basically yeah
um
there are lots of
protocols and specs out there that solve
these exact problems yeah um
so that for example you can open an
invisible iframe and go back to the
token server get a new token for example
yeah or maybe uh or opening an iframe to
the server which sends you notifications
when the user has locked out but
the common denominator was they were all
based on iframes hidden hidden iframes
right because that's like the our one
trick in the toolbox that always works
somehow right
um so yes same thing here with this
application right um
[Music]
you see when i want a new token
look at that
no flickering
yeah job done
[Laughter]
so if i look at sorry not here
but inspect the page
inspect you see
when i'm pressing the renew button you
see that for a very very short moment
there's an iframe going back to the
token server getting a new token that's
what that was the official
recommendation how to do this yeah
also you can see here there's an another
iframe that points to the token server
itself to a special endpoint so so that
the token server at logout time can send
a notification back to the client that
the session is over so they can close
the application basically yeah so when i
now um go to the token server here right
and log out
magic
okay
magic done with iframes
um
so that's how that worked
and we for seven years maintained an
officially certified javascript client
library which implemented all of these
features and just recently like six
months ago we decided to not to
basically archive the project because
you just can't win yeah
regardless what you do the tokens end up
in the browser we had so much trouble
maintaining this library over different
browsers different browser versions even
it was always something
yeah and we decided no a we we don't
want to buy into this approach anymore
and b
it's just too much work
ma'am and now the next thing happens the
browsers are changing as well
yeah so
all of the browser vendors
have agreed that they have to do
something about you know
tracking networks and advertisements and
all of these things and the different
vendors approaching the problem in
different in different ways but
um
basically google has announced a very
big change actually they wanted to make
this change this year but then they got
problems with uh
governments and things because they
would break everything basically so they
delayed just delayed it to trade 2023 if
you want to google for that google for
that it's a it's called the chrome
cookie pocalypse
okay
um
but
you know like most people say yeah as
long as chrome is okay we are fine right
all of these niche browsers like safari
and brave we don't care but guess what
safari has changed their behavior too
and safari has a 20 market share and you
probably have customers using safari
okay so what safari did as the first
step is they now
block cookies in iframes
do you see a problem with all of our
iframe based approaches now
right if there's no cookie flowing
anymore i can't get a new token if
there's no cookie flowing anymore the
server thinks i'm locked out yeah so
when i run this exact same application
that that is working fine here in chrome
on safari
okay
i log in
yep
why
well because the the front end opened
the iframe to to receive the logout
notifications
the the cookie is is blocked by safari
so the talk server says there is no
session you are locked out
okay so you're immediately locked out
and guess what the renewed token doesn't
work either because the cookie is
blocked as well for the renew token
um
requests
yeah so that's today already
and the two browsers which have
implemented this by default now is
safari and brave in firefox you have
like an enhanced security thing if you
click that you you get the same behavior
um the the only two browsers right now
which
do work is chrome
and edge
okay
so that's coming and uh if your
application is built on this um
approach it will not work anymore
in the future so what does this all
affect well silent renew as i just shown
you session notifications uh maybe you
know what a front channel log out
notification is right so when when you
log out let's say from azure id and then
they send like um
logout messages to your applications in
in iframes guess what um to tell them
that the user is locked out right and
again since now these browsers are
blocking the cookies in the iframe
especially um you know across site that
is also not working anymore
right
so what did people end up doing to solve
the problem it's like okay you know what
let's just use refresh tokens in the
browser right refresh tokens give us a
way to manage our token lifetime without
these cookies yeah which is the worst
possible thing you can do from a
security point of view right a
javascript application or a
browser-based application is by
definition a so-called public client in
oauth meaning they don't have a client
secret and now you have a refresh token
in the browser as well if somebody can
steal that refresh token they can
without even knowing your client secret
create new access tokens as long as they
want typically
okay
you know there are popular cloud
management websites
that
use refresh tokens
you know what what could go wrong right
[Laughter]
um okay
so all of these things together
let uh brought us to the decision
this is not the way forward
okay and we don't know what other crazy
things the process will do in the future
so relying on browser behavior here is
not going to work we rather want to
probably play nice with the browsers
like use the security sandbox that they
think is the right one which these days
is the same side policy so if something
comes from the same top level domain
right and the same origin policy which
means your code is running exactly on
the same origin where the server is
running on these are the two security
features of browsers
all of these iframes and the stuff was
working around this right
and now they are shutting it down
so
but there are also good browser changes
um and that is um basically what they
call same site cookies yeah so
the cross site request forgery problem
was enabled by the fact that the browser
when you make a network call it only
checked where is the call going to right
and if you had a call a cookie for app
one somebody in that browser makes a
call to app one the browser sent the
cookie
right with the same site cookies they do
an additional check now and that is
who is actually sending the cookie and
only if the sender and the receiver
match they're on the same domain same
side then they will send the cookie and
now you might ask yourself why wasn't
this like that from the start
we don't know right we'll live and learn
i guess um
right so same side cookies protect you
from cross site request forgery by
default
okay and it's very important to
understand what and what an origin is
and what a site is right and origin is
the exact triple of protocol dns name
and port number that's an origin a site
basically is the
they call it tld minus one which doesn't
help really but let's say you have
mycompany.com then my company is the
site
so if you have app one my company com
app2 my company com app3 and so on then
that is a site and cookies can flow
freely inside but not outside
okay
sounds perfect yeah
but only as long as you're not a victim
to a subdomain takeover attack
sounds scary right uh a sub domain
takeover attack is that an attacker is
able to execute code in your site
and how is that even possible right
um a couple of years ago electronic arts
was hit by that right and um basically
the way this worked is this yeah ea
needed a new
application
so some developer created an azure
website
and wrote this application on on that
website right and then they added a
custom domain to it so basically blah
blah blah websites.net became
billing.ea.com
right
cool so at some point ea said okay we
don't need this anymore we merge this in
into the main application
they shut down the azure website but the
dns entry was still pointing to it
so now you can automate this attack by
querying dns servers and see oh look at
that it's a dangling pointer if you like
to a non-existing azure website so let's
just register the azure website that the
name is free now okay and suddenly you
can write code which runs on the site of
the victim
right
billing.ea.com was now an attacker
website and not an ea website anymore
and then same side cookies won't help
you yeah all i'm saying same that
cookies are a nice way of having a
baseline security in the browser
but it's not the silver bullet
yeah
okay
so
now
fast forwarding
um
browsers browsers on one hand get more
restricted on the other hand have better
security like same side cookies there
are new ietf recommendations again um
one is the the thing called oar for
browser-based applications it's a it's
um not a protocol it's a what they call
a pcp a best current practice and
it's a guidance document if you like
which everyone should read in my opinion
that is building browser-based
applications and is using oauth yeah
and you know oauth was a protocol
designed for doing cross a cross-site
api calls right and funnily enough in
this spec or in this document called
over for browser-based applications one
of the guidance was
if you don't call cross-site apis maybe
you don't need oauth
which is actually very true
okay
which was funny for an oauth working
group document to be honest yeah it's
gone by now but you can you know
if you think reading rfcs is geeky
even geekier is reading the diffs
between different versions of rfcs
and you can find this sentence if you go
back in time because they basically have
version control on it yeah so yeah
that's true yeah um
and
at the same time there's another
document now popping up which is talking
about this bff thing okay so bff stands
for back end for front end and um that's
basically what we're going to talk about
next yeah so the
the the fundamental thing here is that
you have to realize that there are two
types of javascript applications or
blazer applications or whatever you want
to call them the ones with the back end
and the ones without a back end yeah
so the ones without a back end they are
exactly what i just shown you everything
is running in javascript you're doing
the token management in javascript
you're calling the apis in javascript
and you have all the problems i just
shown you yeah
but wasn't that the dream of the spa
people right oh it's just html css and
javascript and it's like a real program
yeah
well it isn't
um
and the bcp says this is okay for low
value applications well you know like
when you're not dealing with sensitive
data so to speak right this pipe dream
of i just put my stuff on a cdn it's
just gonna run in the browser it's all
good yeah
if you're dealing with sensitive data
you don't want to store the sensitive
data in the browser full stop yeah and
the only way you can work around this is
by adding a back end to your application
that
that stores the sensitive data okay
so the idea with the bff approaches is
that the chart that the javascript
itself
does not do any security yeah it just
does what it does best to be honest is
ui right um and all of the
authentication handshakes token storage
token management calling apis is
happening on a dedicated application
back end right that's where bff comes
from backend for front end and maybe
also because they are so tightly coupled
they hopefully are best friends forever
yeah
that's the idea yeah
um
now this new ietf document
makes it
more complicated i think than than it
should be they are they are
distinguishing between two types of two
flavors of bff one is called the full
bay of bff and one is called the tmi bff
and that's the that's an attempt from
the itf to try to be funny tmi stands
for too much information yeah um
yeah i'm still laughing um and um
basically the idea is this the full bff
uh
does all of the security stuff on the
server right and even calling the apis
is happening server to server whereas
the tmi bff has this
you know half baked would be maybe the
wrong word but
in the middle approach
where it says okay we do all of the
token management on the server but then
when you need to call an api we send the
token down to the browser to call the
api
and they also say
the full bf approach offers better
security
right because you only solved half of
the problems here yeah the token will
still end up in the browser and can be
stolen
so that's you know
um
ietf ascii art that's how that looks
like so the idea is right at the front
end wants a token goes to the back end
back and gets the token from the token
server and then sends the token down to
the front end and then the front end can
call the apis directly that's that
that's the team ibff i'm not going to
talk about this because i think this is
only half useful
the one i much more prefer is the full
bff approach where everything is
happening on the server the tokens never
leave the server
the javascript will never do cross-site
communication on its own
but with the one downside of course is
that all of the api calls need to go via
the server so they're getting proxied
right which might be a concern or not
so
now that we know what a bff is
um
let's build one or you know like have a
look how one could look like built with
asp.net core and the nice thing is is
that basically all of the building
blocks are there right so you basically
need a server-side asp.net core
application you plug in an open connect
and oauth client library and we have
really good ones in asp.net they are the
oidc
authentication handler is
probably the best client library i've
ever seen for web-based applications um
we
plug in some session management right so
that we can deal with the cookies going
back and forth between the backend and
the front-end um
again the a spinner core session
management library is really good yeah
and then we plug in some token
management so that you know all of the
getting the token refreshing the token
getting a new token when the old one has
expired thing that part is not built
inside of asp.net core but there's a
library that can help you with that
um
and then you'd have to deal with your
api endpoints and then ultimately you
have the ui assets
yeah
so so just to reiterate before we move
on yeah the idea is this
you go to the application you start it
you go to an application server the
application server serves the static
assets down to your to your browser
whenever you want to start your
authentication handshake you're calling
an endpoint in your application server
which then in turn starts the handshake
the tokens coming back from the
authentication handshake will be stored
on the server yeah the server will
create a session for you which is cookie
based same side cookies and all the
bells and whistles that we can do to
make it secure as secure as possible and
even something more which i'll show you
in a second
and then
from that point on the communication
between front end and back end is always
being secured via this session cookie
yeah and whenever the
the browser or the the front that needs
to make a call
to something that is not living in its
back end the back end is proxying into
the remote location
attaching the access token and sending
the response back
to the
browser right and that might sound a
little bit you know uh that's that's
that's a pretty old school but yeah from
a security point of view that's the only
way to do it in my opinion
so as i said that's that um full
disclosure i've built such a framework
before it's part of of identity server
but that's not the point i want to show
you
what we did basically
and the building blocks as i said
besides token management are all part of
asp.net core the first of all we need a
way to serve our static content right
that is the static files middleware in
in asp.net core that's the thing that
serves down your javascript your html
your css and whatever else you need
right
we need authentication that's the
asp.net core open id connect handler and
then we need to think about how to
secure the communication between the
front end and the back end and let's
start with the authentication as i said
that's just the standard openid connect
handler you see
um on the server side you point it to
your trusted server
the nice thing now is is that you know
by definition a spa running in the in
the
in the browser doing javascript is
always a public client it cannot have a
secret by moving that logic to the
server you turn it into a confidential
client which does have a secret and can
authenticate with the token server right
which is great
and then
basically all you need to do is um
expose some local endpoints in your
backend to be able to trigger the login
and log out functionality of your of
your server right so let's do this first
let's go to the javascript sample here
so for all of you are doing uh you know
standard asp.net core this looks pretty
familiar
um here's our startup file right
um we're adding authentication here we
are setting our cookie
uh we can use the strictest same side
modes of all because we are not you know
so
for those who don't know there are three
modes for same side one is called um
well none which means you you don't have
protection one is called lags which
means only post requests block the
cookie cross side boundaries and
strict means even get requests are
getting blocked the cookies are getting
blocked across side boundary now which
one to choose here well
lex
always lacks
strict might be not compatible with your
application because let's say you have a
link going to another application that
simple link will not transfer cookies
over so that might not work for you but
as we all know we don't change system
state based on get requests so lags
would be good enough so the post
requests don't get cookies anymore
across site boundaries
then here's my open id connect handler
oh and by the way that that's another
nice thing here um
it's not not really um an official
standard but all browsers understand it
if you do a underscore underscore host
prefix on the cookie you prevent sub
domains to overwrite that cookie
which is another attack that by the way
is possible in browsers that's why many
many years ago you remember that
github.com had the user pages also on
github.com
and there was an attack found by a very
clever guy who found out that if you are
over you can override in the subdomain
the cookie of the main domain
was kind of fun and that's when github
moved
github.com as its own web asset and then
the user page are on github io right so
just get it get a different domain name
that this cookie thing cannot happen
anymore and this underscore underscore
hosting prevents this as well
okay
um yeah and then we just you know ask
for api access here ask for a refresh
token so we can do token management and
that's pretty much it yeah
um
so let's run this
okay
everybody needs to do application
um
so you see where now that the spa wants
to trigger
the actually pretty complicated open
body connect authentication workflow
with all its spells and whistles and
front-end back-end channel communication
and so on all it needs to do is you see
go to the local endpoint called login
that's all the front-end needs to know
about right login
i login
and i'm logged in
okay
and logout is the same story right we
just trigger log out on the on the back
end and then the whole thing will be
reversed
that's nice
um
compared to the actually i'm kidding you
not thousands of lines of code we had in
our
openly connect client javascript library
yeah
right so now we have a session with the
server okay so now um we're gonna secure
this session with this um with this
cookie handler i just showed you use the
same side mode use the host prefix and
so on so now we basically have sandboxed
our communication to the same site
okay
um
and now you know your your javascript
client might want to know who is the
user or maybe there are claims about
that user that they care about right so
the next thing you all only have to do
is expose another endpoint let's call it
user right which then
sends the contents of the session as
json back to the client
okay so let's do that as well
uh show session information and you can
see apparently security is much easier
for me than ui
um
i i don't care about uis you know
but basically that is the server-side
session right and um there's a way to to
send this down to the client and maybe
because the client wants to know the
name of the user right or maybe they
need to know i don't know his favorite
color or whatever right
um
you could even use this you know
periodically to query the server side
session state like is the user still
logged in for example yeah if you want
to do something like this
and quite nice actually starting with
dot net six
um you know when we wrote this yeah and
thought about like does it make sense to
pull the server let's say every minute
to ask
let's say you want to implement an
inactivity
counter something like this right so
imagine now you would you would ping the
server every one minute but the server
is configured for sliding expiration
cookies you would extend
the session time every time you're doing
the ping right so we opened an issue
with microsoft and hey um
it's the new microsoft they fixed it
so now starting with dotnet six there's
a way that you can dynamically suppress
sliding cookies
okay so imagine now you have this user
endpoint you put in like a special query
string parameter slide false you can
handle an event on the cookie handler
and if you see that query string you say
don't slide the cookie
and that means after some time the
session will be expired and that's
exactly what we want right
okay cool um
what else do we have token management so
that's the only part
where asp.net core does not help you now
that's a long-standing discussion with
microsoft
um
but
basically
it's not implemented yeah and what
session what token management means is
of course that now that the server is
keeping the tokens um and doing the api
calls right you have to make sure that
your token is still valid yeah so
um after a certain amount of time the
token will be expired then there's the
refresh token that you can use to get a
new token right and so on actually maybe
i can quickly show you that as well we
have some time
um there's a sample here
i might need to
shut down
the other
client
and we see
so yeah let me just show you that
and then i'll show you how it how it
works so when i log in here
right you see that inside the session so
that that's pretty much poking into the
session of html core on the server side
what's in there you see in a spirit core
they store the access token in the
session they store
um the refresh token in the session and
they also have something called expires
ad and with these three values you can
imagine right you can write some
automated logic saying like okay i know
when the token expires now i i want to
use it it's expired here's the refresh
token let's under under the covers get a
new access token
get rid of the old access token store
that you want in the session and all
runs smoothly without you having to
pollute your business logic with that
token management code okay
um
i don't have to run this because it's
actually pretty boring to look at
exploration times here and see oh a new
token yeah um
but
um the way this is wired up and that
that's just pure magic yeah i mean the
a-spirit core system is so extensible
so basically all of that what i just
described is by getting by using one
line of code
okay and this is basically wiring up all
kinds of stuff in the background to to
monitor the session monitor the expires
ad thing and then all you have to do is
say like hey um
http hp client factory register a client
that is wired up to the automatic token
management so whenever i'm using this
client now from the factory it will
under the covers automatically
do token management for me right and
actually if we look at the code
um to do that it's super simple right
all you need to do is say hey client
factory give me a client and then do an
api call so you don't care anymore with
token exploration attaching the token
refreshing the token and so on and so
forth yeah
so that's nice that's a library written
by me
that is free just plug it in into your
application and
you know should work
okay
so coming back to this guy
oh i'm still locked in no
let's see log out
okay
log in again
cool
so what else is missing oh yeah now this
is a tricky one
session change notifications right so um
as i said the old the old session state
a session change notification mechanism
using iframes doesn't work anymore yeah
so um
are there are really only two ways of um
of doing this now the one i just
mentioned by probably pulling your back
end periodically into like is he still
locked in is he still locked in
or
by sending some sort of event down from
the server
to the client right but the first
problem you have to solve is how does
the your backend know that the user has
locked out from the token server right
again front channel not notifications
rely on iframes they don't work anymore
there's a another standard here called
back channel notifications um that you
can use and modern
identity systems support that
and the idea is basically instead of
relying on the browser to send you a
notification basically the token server
sends a server to server call to the
backend saying hey dominic has locked
out okay and when then the server sees
that event or that notification coming
in they can delete the session server
side which then triggers a notification
on the client side and that gives you
the log out behavior so to speak okay
um yeah and you can implement this
endpoint yeah and that's another thing
missing in asp.net core right now at
least but um
this will come right because microsoft's
premiere
identity product azure id
runs by definition always cross site
to your company website right so the
front channel stuff will not work
anymore so they have to implement this
sooner or later
cool so last last thing i want to talk
about is now now we want to call apis
okay
um
so when we work with our customers to
refactor
their spas to this new style
we often find found out that there are
fundamentally two types of apis they
have one type of api is they are which
are
just exclusive for the front end no one
else is calling them besides the front
end okay
um and if you find those apis
then you can just put them in the back
end right what's the point of making
complicated cross server calls
whatsoever just put them in the back end
and you know you can secure them with
the session yeah
the other type of api that you probably
find are shared apis where you see like
multiple people are calling this yeah
multiple clients are sharing that api
and in that case well you should make it
shareable by putting it on a dedicated
endpoint and then use the the proxy
technique so to speak to to call them
okay
so
another nice trick that that i learned
while building this framework is um so
let's say you know we have we have same
side cookies they are great they are
free right because they are implemented
by the browser but they only secure us
against attacks across site
yeah so what if we have this attack
scenario where someone runs on the same
site um
and uh i didn't found this out there's a
very smart guy that i know who who told
me this trick
called philippe
um
[Music]
all you have to do to protect your api
calls um
even b even
tighter than same site is just by
putting in a custom header on the api
call it doesn't really matter what what
header it is you can call it foo and bar
it doesn't matter right
we call it xc serve and the value is
static it's a one yeah and that looks
totally strange right knowing all of the
complicated stuff microsoft is doing
with anti-forgery tokens and so on but
it turns out
since we are now requiring a cookie to
call the local api endpoint
meaning you make an hx call and you have
to say with credentials right and if you
are in addition adding a custom header
to the ajax call the browser will always
kick off a cause pre-flight request
okay so cause is the thing which tries
to negotiate can we call api's
cross-site so it will always kick this
off because you are while violating the
rules you are a sending a cookie and
you're sending a custom header it
doesn't really matter what the header is
but that's it and what you know cause
has two types of checks the one course
check is let's just do the call and on
the way back we check the course policy
and if it doesn't
fulfill the policy we just don't pass
the data back to the javascript yeah
and the other one is called the
preflight request where course first
asks the server
are you okay with calling you
and if the server says no
then it will not call the server
what's the big difference here as well
think about spectre attacks again yeah
with the first approach the data is in
the ram of the browser with the second
approach the data will never arrive at
the browser
okay
so that's cool
i mean i was blown away when i learned
about this yeah um
right and basically all you have to do
is put in a little bit of middleware in
your pipeline that checks every api call
has this header set job done
okay
that's what we do basically um here uh
here that's that's the middleware that
is basically checking for this um
for this uh static xc serve header and
if it's not present it will reject the
call
yeah um
and then you can actually mark the end
points in your application
that this endpoints want this extra
security check
right you might have other endpoints
which don't want this maybe we want to
intentionally allow it across the cross
origin scenario but if you mark it like
this then all end points here in this
case mbc endpoints are secured by the
extra check
um
right and if i now run the front end
right i can you see
create to-do's and that is calling a
local api endpoint right just to prove
i'm not cheating that is actually
working
okay
good
and the last thing is remote apis
so if you need to call apis which live
on a different server well then in this
with this pattern you need to proxy the
calls okay
um how you proxy them is totally up to
you
there are fundamentally i guess three
things you could do one is create a
local api endpoint that gives you you
know that that takes the local call and
then turns around and makes another api
call to the other server right that is
maybe good for smaller api services if
you realize you have to replicate a
whole remote api in the local thing that
might not be the
what you want right then you could
employ some sort of reverse proxy
technique yeah
there's actually a nice reverse proxy
now for asp.net core called yap
it's a weird name it stands for yet
another reverse proxy
um
and think of it as an in-app reverse
proxy it integrates into your asp.net
host and you basically can say you know
when you get a call on this uh end point
just
transparently proxy the call to the
other endpoint
right
and that's what we used and the way this
looks like is now basically you go to
your endpoint mappings you say okay
whenever you get a call on api in the
local application which is secured by
the session and blah blah right um turn
around go to this other api and by the
way while doing that attach the current
access token of the user so from an api
point of view it looks like as if the
front end would have called the api
directly
okay
so yeah so just to show you that
so you know here's my to-do controller
right so let's just uh
don't use this anymore
go here
and
enable the reverse proxy so run my
front-end host again
and run the back-end host which now has
the the you know the shared to-do
controller yeah
back and api host
and then in the browser
i create something
and it just continues working without
having to change the front end at all
right it's transparent for the front end
good
so that's pretty much
our conclusion how to solve this problem
yeah after having all of these painful
years of doing this and this stopped
working then doing this and this stopped
working and this had this problem and so
on so as i said from a security point of
view that is the the recommended
technique and we have more and more
customers where there's just a you know
a statement uh all new spas
must not have
uh tokens stored locally in the browser
that's the requirement from a security
point of view
and that's the only way how you can
actually solve this
that i know about
good
so we have three more minutes
any questions
really
[Laughter]
for a few
years serverless applications
what they're basically saying now is
that if you have any security
considerations at all
i don't know
several several is such a buzzword
i'm not sure if that clashes right um
this this is
so the way i understand serverless is
it's a hosting model
right but you're ultimately still
running some sort of host on the back
end and if that host has all the
features that you need to to to manage
sessions and manage tokens totally fine
right all i'm saying is um
if you mean serverless me with there is
no server
then this is the wrong approach okay
any other questions
yeah
loud
so yeah so the way this works is
basically
is you do here that there's a new event
called option start event start
something with sliding on check sliding
expiration okay so you implement this
event and then you look for example for
a special query string coming in and
when you see that query string you
return
some true or false or whatever right and
then they don't slide the cookie
anything else another question yeah
huh there are
a couple of new or specifications
neutral tls
and
i'm just just thinking
if you implement one of them wouldn't
so
so first okay so the question is with
d-pop and mt-less which probably sounds
like greek words to most people here but
um
is it viable so first of all mtls you
can't use in the browser yeah it's not
designed for browsers depop
[Music]
i don't think so because still with
depop the
secret the key must be available to the
caller
and again you where do you store the key
now
it will again end up in javascript
somehow right
but i agree with you that what i see as
a win is is that with this approach on
the server side you can easily do mtls
and you can easily do depop right all of
these extra security standards that pop
up they are pretty i mean
mtls is it was designed for server to
server communication right and it's it's
probably the most secure we have right
now um and depop is possible in the
browser but everyone is well aware that
this will not
solve the cross-site scripting problem
right
so yeah
you can make it harder right and but in
security you always assume a motivated
and skilled hacker
right
and um they will find out how that works
when you can inject javascript you can
inject arbitrary com complex javascript
you can install event handlers right i
mean all kinds of stuff you can do in
javascript yeah so
yeah um
so you're saying
i i'm hitting the call centers on the
front end
actually i'm not that's the trick here
i'm not adding the course headers right
by omitting the course headers i locked
it down to same origin right and that
that's only relevant for browser to
back-end calls and then on the server no
one cares about cores
right
yeah
you skipped one of the slides
it's not important um
it's really useful it's great okay
so you have to be a
um the customer is um what we call the
fair trade
policy
is if your company makes less than one
million it's free if they make more than
one million in a year you can afford it
yeah
which i think is the way forward for
open source
okay thanks for your time
enjoy the rest of the day
you